one of the things that was very  interesting that I discovered was when I  was preparing for a lecture for one of  my speeches in Canada I needed to  research feminism and the feministic  movement there and it was really  interesting to find out that the whole  movement in that country actually  started from a group of Christian women  who were not happy with the fact that  the missionary work had been actually  designated for men only and you know  that's something very interesting  because in Islam since the advent of  Islam women have had the opportunity to  teach and to go forth and give Dawa and  share the message of Islam and even  today I travel all over and share the  message of Islam with people in in every  type of venue so it's it's very  interesting that that you know existed  at that time the need to have this  feministic movement to be able to  practice their religion fully whereas  Muslim women have enjoyed this for you  know fourteen hundred and thirty-five  years